I think the part of the end of the
pre-created linear Christian positivist
dispensation etc etc is the recognition
that that mind extends infinitely in all
directions it isn't all rationally
apprehend about to the primate neural
architecture but the ocean thing the
continent thing the solar system things
the Sun of things who can rethink what
they think
probably not but then an infinite
frontier of potential intellectual
evolution opens up through the concept
of an unlimited project of understanding
you know whitehead once pushed on the
subject of understanding said
understanding is the a perception of
pastoring as such that's all it is
patterning as such well any given
context of meaningful of people a coral
reef of planetary system will display if
you observe it carefully enough an
infinite number of patterns as such and
they should discover one and then
another and then another you feel this
AHA experience which we associate with
the an epiphany of understanding one of
the coolest things that a human being
can experience so this is why what Mark
said last night about virtual reality
being a tool for seeing nature at
different scale is so
that gets my wheels turning because I
want to see planetary processes I want
to see the heat flow from the polar ice
caps to the equator I want to understand
the salinity of the oceans I want to
grasp the speed at which volcanism is
altering the seafloor and the atmosphere
well these are gone this is what God you
know if it's around and watch this
creation on at the interesting scale and
and it not only can be done it is being
done and it will be done better and
better and you know the oh there was the
old cliche back at the dawn of the Space
Age as guys went into orbit for the
first time and out to the moon the
Epiphany of seeing the whole earth at
one and they said what we can't explain
into but when you see it you know a
Bluegreen piece spinning in the darkness
you can you're never the same well we
all can see that and much more you can
see to the mantle you can pull out to
the Oort cloud and see the entire solar
system shrink down to a spinning dot you
can lose that in the vastness and all of
this stuff is not without consequence
people the virtual reality and some
people's mouth becomes almost a
dismissive term but that's because their
objectification free and don't
understand that the power is in the
infirmary
you know I mean I feel that I've been on
the surface of Titan that I understand
the lava fields of you that I've walked
to the valley of Mars because I've been
to all those places information referral
life the air is the better
[Music]